he said um
basically there's the instructions
so I watched the films about sentencing
yeah it's not the other female
and he would just use a bundle of six uh
honest
and you can see I said it's on the old
videos of striking videos
and he strikes the weather with cycle
since the up in the mountain but uh and
you can plan on Save the same YouTubers
but what what I why I designed them the
way I I have
and then he would he would fight
someone might be invisible people it was
the other idea
or sometimes he would do it he would
like him inside the sensing and then go
to Italian
so he was he was trying to vary it
was
but the idea is to stabilize your hips
learn how to have stable hips out and
you don't when you're moving
he goes you also learn how to be stable
so so the termination to me is very
important
the last one
[Music]
is changing
things
okay so you're changing the feet
yeah
and this one especially look for the
what caused sideways balance
[Music]
does it take a little bit one way
because it's difficult
not just because you're you're
right-handed
but even if you held it
incorrectly
[Music]
if you go to control
all right
it's the fourth degree